تقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو
بلنكن ان على الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
اتخاذ خطوات فوريه لوقف التصعيد وفي مؤتمر
صحفي مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بالقدس
اكد بلنكن على ضروره الحفاظ على الوضع
القائم في الاماكن المقدسه بالقدس مشددا
على اهميه حل الدولتين كضمان لابني
اسرائيل
دائره الاتفاقيات مع دول جديده نحن نسعى
الى توسيع دائره السلام وبالتاكيد هذا ليس
بديلا للتقدم بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين يمكننا للقيام بذلك تحسين
حياه الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه غزه
فلسطين واسرائيل يتمتعان سويا بحريه وفراس
وامن وعداله وكرامه نحن مقتنعون بان افضل
طريق للحصول على هذا هو الحفاظ على حل
الدولتين واي شيء يبعدنا عن هذه الرؤيه
يبعدنا عن الامن المستدامه لاسرائيل وعن
اسرائيل كدوله يهوديه
الذي جمع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ورئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي معنا من امام مقر
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في القدس مراسله
الجزيره وجد وقفي وجدي يعني همم تحدثنا في
نشره سابقه ما جاء في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
من الرسائل لكن ال- ال- الرساله الاهم قد
تكون هي دعوه وزير خارجيه الطرفين لاتخاذ
خطوات فوريه
لوقف هذا التصعيد هل اتضحت ما هي تلك
الخطوات التي دعا اليها الجانب الامريكي
عبر وزير الخارجيه
لم ياخذ في التفاصيل وربما هذا ما ناقشه
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي اليوم خلال اجتماعه
مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي هو بالمناسبه
حاليا وزير خارج الامريكي يعقد اجتماعا مع
نظيره الاسرائيلي همم وزير خارجيه اسرائيل
في المقابله ايضا هذه الدعوه ذاتها نتوقع
ان يوجهها للجانب الفلسطيني ايضا لدى
لقائه مع رئيس السلطه الفلسطينيه الرئيس
الفلسطينيين دعوات التهدئه جاء الى هنا
همم مع هذه الرساله وايضا مع التركيز على
الاعتقاد الراسخ لدى اداره الرئيس بان
الحل الافضل
للوقف هذا التصعيد ولكي يعيش كما قال بل
يمكن الاسرائيليون في امن كمان هو حل
الدولتين التوصل الى سلام بين جانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي بلنكن شدد ايضا على
ضروره العيش الكريم
الفلسطينيين هنا وبالتالي هي رساله واضحه
من قبل الجانب الامريكي لكن غير الواضح
ايمان هو همم استراتيجيه الاداره ماذا بعد
دعوات هل ستضغط الاداره الامريكيه على
حكومه نتنياهو من اجل تحقيق هذه الدعوات
والاهداف التي جاء من اجلها حتى الان لا
يلوح في الافقه اي امكانيه لان تضغط
الاداره الامريكيه على اسرائيل من اجل وقف
عمليات التنكيل ضد الفلسطينيين سواء كان
على صعيد القوات الاسرائيليه قوه الاحتلال
او على الصعيد ايضا المستوطنين
واعتداءاتهم شبه اليوميه على
الفلسطينيين التوقعات سقفها منخفض حقيقه
سواء كان بالنسبه للجانب الفلسطيني او حتى
لدى الاسرائيليين هنا خاصه واننا سمعنا من
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي حديثه عن السلام
وبان اسرائيل مع السلام لكن على ارض
الواقع ما تقوم به اسرائيل هو تنكيل هو
ابعاد فلسطينيين هو هدم منازل فلسطينيين
واجراءات تصعيديه اخرى وانتقاميه بحق
الشعب الفلسطيني
من القدس